[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday we begin this half hour with
the waning days of summer and crowds
packing the beaches but for some a
simple trip to the shore was once a
daunting challenge until one woman with
a vision of inclusion stepped in to help
manuel bajorkas reports from miami beach
for sergio echeverria this isn't just a
day at the beach
[Music]
nicknamed aquaman the ocean has always
been his second home but a tractor
accident this winter left him a
quadriplegic did you think you'd ever be
able to get back in the water again i
had my doubt
i really did but here you are i did and
i've been proven wrong
and i like that
once a month a small army of volunteers
build out this stretch of miami beach
plastic mats for the wheelchairs and
special floating chairs transporting
folks for a joyful swim
it's amazing you said it's not just the
water but it's the people around you too
i have found out that in the water
i find my best family my best friends
sabrina cohen is the woman behind these
adaptive beach days i'm crying of joy
so when you see people
go into the water for the first time
in years
we all cry
it's like tears of joy it's um it's a
gift to give to others
cohen is among the 61 million u.s adults
living with a disability a car accident
left her a quadriplegic at 14. for a
moment when you're in the water you're
like anybody else any mobility devices
that you use just wash away for a moment
they wash away you're floating that's
the great equalizer it sure is dr susan
solman calls it a magical experience
without this just getting onto the beach
you wouldn't be able to do it now
every time i go in the water
it becomes the greatest day of my life
it truly is
sabrina cohen is now working to install
a permanent location on miami beach to
date we have welcomed over 8 000
people from not only over south florida
but from all over the world 8 000 people
8 000 people correct what does that feel
like it's like a small strand of
miracles that just keep coming together
each one with a smile that just washes
over for cbs this morning saturday
manuel bajorquez miami beach
love it go aquaman you really see the
joy on everybody's face there not just
the people who are experiencing it in
the water with these mobility devices
but all of the people around to help and
also and also watching on tv yes